it's no secret that Dubai and Abu Dhabi
are not the best of friends
of course they'll stand by each other in
times of crisis like when Dubai was on
the brink of bankruptcy during the 2008
financial crisis and the Central Bank of
Abu Dhabi lent out billions of dollars
to Dubai to continue operation which
they have yet to pay off however aside
from that there is no doubt this endless
rivalry between the two Emirates to
represent the UAE on the world stage
just take a look at them
for instance Dubai has Emirates and Abu
Dhabi as Etihad similarly Dubai has a
palm island while Abu Dhabi has ayan Rai
and of course they both have endless
lists about sandy hotels and tourist
attractions and this isn't a recent
rivalry either Abu Dhabi and Dubai have
been find out to each other well before
the UAE was even formed in 1971 Dubai
and Abu Dhabi have seen this rivalry
ever since they were tribe is led by
various ruling families considering this
when the UAE was formed how did Dubai
that Abu Dhabi become the capital well
the answer is that they didn't the UAE
was formed in December of 1971 after a
prison left area after deciding it
wasn't a good financial investment in
March of that year in need of the Union
for protection and stability six
emirates including Abu Dhabi and Dubai
combined on December 2nd 1971 later on
on February 10th 1972 the seventh
emirate Ra's al khaimah joined the
Federation and these are the seven
emirates that make up the UAE today
though all of these femoris had a degree
of rivalry the strongest is between Abu
Dhabi and Dubai as they couldn't come to
a decision and the other immersed feared
overpowering it was decided that none of
the Emirates will become the capital the
UAE plan to create a neutral City
between Dubai and Abu Dhabi similar to
how Canberra was chosen as Australia's
capital between Sydney and Melbourne the
capital was to be called al Karim WA and
was to be built on land forfeited by
both Dubai and Abu Dhabi even today you
can see remnants of this decision if we
take a look at the telephone
codes in the UAE you'll see that there's
no city - the telephone code 0 1 Abu
Dhabi is o2 and Dubai is o4 this is
because o 1 was reserved for the new
capital all Kurama another fun fact is
that there is no area code o8 this code
was actually reserved for Qatar but they
back out of join the federation and
formed their own country not only this
but the plan to create a new capital
city called al qiyamah
was clearly detailed in the UAE
constitution in article 9 the
Constitution puts out three major
classes running this issue that first
reads the capital of the Union shall be
established in an area allotted to the
Union by the emirate of Abu Dhabi and
Dubai on the borders between them and
they shall be given the name al Kurama
the second clause reads there shall be
allocated in the union budget for the
first year the amount necessary to cover
expenses of technical studies and
planning for the construction of the
capital however construction work shall
begin as soon as possible and shall be
completed not more than 7 years from the
date of entry in the forest of this
constitution so clearly this was not
expected to take a long time and should
have been completed by the 1980's the
final Clause reads until the
construction of the Union capitals
complete Abu Dhabi shall be the
provisional headquarters of the Union on
top of this Abu Dhabi was only allowed
to be the capital for a maximum of five
years at which point the capital will be
passed to another city if al Kurama was
still incomplete Abu Dhabi was initially
chosen as they were the most financially
stable due to their rich oil reserves as
you can guess all Kurama was never
constructed and Abu Dhabi remained the
capital and the reason for this is
actually quite anticlimactic you see the
ruler of Abu Dhabi Sheikh Zayed had been
working on transforming Abu Dhabi into a
forest and as a result he had been
planting thousands of trees many of
which had fallen to a new demarcated
zone of all Kurama
originally the plan was that all krama
construction would begin after the trees
in the region that would be chopped down
were equalized by replanting trees in
other
but this never came to fruition and
construction just kept getting delayed
while this was a setback the Kiwis all
Kurama construction was not a priority
was because Abu Dhabi didn't become a
dominant capital like the Emirates
feared in fact Abu Dhabi ruled exactly a
quarter Constitution which gave the
Emirates most of the power even today
the federal government of the UAE only
holds one-third of the power the federal
government only controls defense Foreign
Affairs currency management and
communications everything else is left
for the Emirates to decide independently
this is why each emirate is almost like
an independent nation just without
borders clearly the formation of the UAE
was primarily for political and
financial purposes and as Abu Dhabi
respected this and didn't overstep their
powers other emirates didn't really mind
Abu Dhabi staying as the capital on top
of this the UAE was going exponentially
within the first decade because they
were helping each other grow which
replaced their initial unease with long
lasting bond between each other
eventually as construction was never
started in 1996 the UAE Supreme Council
added an amendment to the Constitution
which removed all provisions of article
9 and replaced it with a new clause that
declared Abu Dhabi to be the new capital
of the UAE and that's how to buy as well
as the other emirates let Abu Dhabi
become the capital what's ironic is that
originally demarcated area of a Kurama
is actually becoming a world centre very
soon as this is very close to where the
do by 2020 Expo will be held in a ways
if you guys thought this video explained
the story of how Abu Dhabi became the
capital then make sure drop a like and
consider subscribing if you like to see
more questions just like this one
logically answered but until then I'm
hari I'll see you guys on the next one